géographie 3e année la métropole
nord-américaine le plan en
damier contrairement à la métropole
européenne qui est construite autour
d'une structure radioconcentrique la
métropole nord-américaine est structurée
suivant un plan en damier vous voyez sur
ces deux extraits de Google Maps l'un
concernant New York et l'autre
concernant Seattle que la structure
n'est pas du tout celle qu'on retrouve
dans des grandes villes comme Paris ou
Londres
ici vous remarquez que les rues sont
parallèles entre elles et que ces rues
parallèles sont elles-même coupé par
d'autres axes qui leur sont parfaitement
perpendiculaires c'est cela que l'on
appelle la structure en damier vous
remarquez que c'est également le cas
dans d'autres quartiers de New York mais
aussi dans d'autres sur d'autres plans
comme ici sile on remarque cette
structure qui est toujours très
géométrique d'O vient cette
STR lorsque l'on passe à une vue
aérienne on constate également cette
structure vous remarquez ici entre les
différents bâtiments les axes qui sont
parallèles entre eux et eux-mêmes on
peut deviner qu'ils sont coupés par des
perpendiculaires voyez que c'est
également le cas ici de l'autre
côté sur l'autre
rive pour le plan endamier nous avons
donc donc une structure qui est
parfaitement géométrique tandis que sur
la structure radioconcentrique comme
nous l'avons vu précédemment on a la
présence de différentes couronnes qui
sont elles-mêmes reliées par des rayons
qui partent du centre ver l'extérieur la
structure est donc radicalement
différente entre la métropole
nord-américaine et la métropole
européenne les caractéristiques du plan
amier ce sont d'abord des axes rectiline
donc c'est-à-dire des routes bien
droites qui se croisent vraiment à angle
droit et qui forment finalement entre
elles des unités spatiales ou en tout
cas des portions de territoire en
rectangle ou en
carré le plan damier n'est pas forcément
quelque chose de récent puisque dans
certaines cités greces ou du monde
romain on trouve des structures
enendamié ici vous avez le plan de
Pompéi et vous voyez que on retrouve des
axes rectiligne coupé
perpendiculairement par d'autres axes on
a donc très tôt cette structure endam en
fait ce sont des villes qui vont être
construites par un seul architecte selon
des plans très précis généralement qui
sont endamés ça va être aussi le cas de
villes qui vont être construites
rapidement comme les villes
nord-américaines à un certain moment on
a de grands espaces à aménager en très
peu de temps et il semble que le plan
amier est beaucoup plus efficace qu'une
structure
radioconcentrique enfin des villes comme
françaises comme par exemple Havre ont
une structure
endamier voyez ici le
j'ai bien toujours mes parallèles et mes
axes perpendiculaires qui viennent
couper ces parallèles en fait ce sont
des villes par exemple qui vont être
détruites pendant un conflit pendant une
guerre et qui doivent être reconstruites
en une seule fois et en quelques années
alors à ce moment-là on a on a adopté
souvent une structure
endamée quels sont les avantages et les
inconvénient d'une structure endamier
ben le gros avantage de la structure
amier ou du plan endamier c'est une
gestion rationnelle de l'espace
c'est-à-dire que vraiment tout l'espace
est utilisé on ne perd aucun centimètre
carré tout est vraiment aménagé et
utilisé contrairement à une structure
radioconcentrique où on va parfois avoir
des impasses et où on va
avoir des maisons qui vont être par
exemple au milieu de certains axes il
faudra reculer l'axe donc c'est beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins rationnelle la
structure
radioconcentrique maintenant la le plan
endamier a quelques inconvénient tout
d'abord on ne sait pas circuler en
diagonale voyez que si je veux aller
d'un point à l'autre de la ville ben je
vais devoir faire toute une série de
détours je prendre une autre couleur
pour vous montrer ça voilà je vais
devoir zigzaguer entre les rues pour
arriver à ma destination ce qui n'est
pas très rapide et ce qui fait perdre
vraiment du temps quand on se déplace en
même temps cette structure ne permet pas
d'élargir les routes de façon facile
très facile
et donc on va être vite vite à trroit
beaucoup de métropoles nord-américaines
sont actuellement ben connaissent leur
centre historique complètement surchargé
de circulation parce que c'est beaucoup
trop étroit et on ne sait plus recouler
les bâtiments étant donné que le moindre
espace le moindre centimè carré de
surface a été construit enfin vous avez
cette image aussi euh des villes
nord-américaine qui se ressemble un peu
toute on a une monotonie du paysage et
certains diront que les ville en damier
ne sont pas très belles enfin c'est très
difficile d'implanter une ville enamier
quand il y a un relief important voilà
un petit peu les inconvénients du plan
enam cette vidéo est déjà finie je reste
à votre disposition si vous avez des
questions en classe et n'hésitez pas à
revisionner s'il y avait des choses ou
des éléments que vous n'avez pas compris
merci à bientôt